249 million dollars to support
palestinian refugees an agreement on the
three-year initiative was signed in the
occupied territory by a european union
delegation and the un's agency for the
refugees unra
98 million dollars is earmarked for this
year
eu ambassador says it's important to
continue supporting the u.n agency until
a political solution for palestine
refugees is found is life-saving is
essential it's indispensable
until we find a solution where the 5
million refugees of palestinian origin
find a home either in their land of
origin
or in the areas where they are
temporarily are being hosted
unra has seen an increase in demand for
its services as the number of registered
palestinian refugees has increased along
with their levels of poverty
more than 1.2 million palestinians in
gaza rely on the agency for food aid
health and education
more than 80 percent of the population
live in poverty and over 60 percent are
unemployed but the u.n agency warned
that the money isn't enough to fund
what's needed whilst this contribution
is significant it doesn't fully cover
the gap that we will have this year on
our funding
at this stage we
understand we're still going to be about
100 million dollars short for our
regular programming for refugees in the
region in 15 years gaza has seen five
wars
hundreds of escalations and airstrikes
and israel's blockade that's kept many
people in the territory in despair
killed thousands and destroyed
infrastructure
israel's tight restrictions on patients
leaving the besieged enclave for
treatment and on the entry of medical
equipment and medication have also left
gus's health system in crisis let me
remind you one third of the cancer
patients in gaza only are permitted
to have access to west bank or israelis
and facilities one-third only what
happens to the rest we don't have a
cancer hospital here
under israel's blockade the territory is
isolated from the outside world and many
here say as long as it goes on its 2.3
million people will continue to be
deprived of basic necessities yumneseet
al jazeera gaza